pink tax is a term for the extra amount
charge for certain products or services
that are specifically marketed towards
female consumers if it existed but it
wasn't until I read this article that I
realized how much 13 more and it's like
the deodorant is pretty much the same
but you put a little flower on it and
then we gotta like spend more money and
I bet dupacers are even better if we
could buy dudes deodorant to be cheaper
or buy like one product and decide that
you're just both going to use that like
we stopped buying like lotion for him
lotion for her and we just buy one plus
my husband barely uses the lotion which
that's a problem in and of itself
moisturize your skin people